hi I'm very happy to see you all here my
name is archon I'm a software engineer
at day and a physicist at night past
eight years I've been working with
different kind of analytics starting
from computational fluid dynamics to
business Analytics
today I want to share this story which
is a bit the personal one but I think
you will find something useful for any
project you're making not only the date
visualization but that's something that
yeah visualization is something that I
like
in the end like I'm very easy to inspire
person and yeah initially I thought that
visualization is something that is well
you just go and you just plot and that's
easy as a piece of cake but as you might
use from the title of my talk it was
absolutely not the case the bumps on the
road the many and I'm here to share some
learnings that I learned along the way
so that's how my journey look like
and when I look back uh and into my
journey I can say that well there were
many mistakes but if I try to summarize
them I could definitely see say that I
didn't know the rules how to make the
good data visualization what makes the
visualization good
I spent too much time on pretty fine the
graphs without actually adding any value
to the stakeholders that I'm creating
those those graphs
uh it was a nightmare to version my code
because I love Jupiter notebooks I ended
up in a huge directory of various
Jupiter notebooks that I cannot manage
at some point and it was a nightmare
uh I was thinking that it's very hard to
break data visualization so I learned
that okay it's actually possible
I made a mistake when I had to reprocess
all the data when you know like all the
fire is around and then you just run
with a glass of water trying to well to
stop this fire from from continuing I've
been in that situation so yeah I learned
a few things and uh yeah so I had to
reproduce the data and today I'm here to
share some learnings that I learned
along the way and maybe some practices
that could help you to avoid those kind
of mistakes
but before we start to talk about the
specifics let's just talk about
visualization in general and as I said
like for me when someone says like hey
we have some data I mean can you help
with visualization I usually very easy
to inspire I go and I say yes of course
let's get it and let's do it and I have
like very colorful images in my head how
it should look like but in reality what
I've learned is that when someone comes
to you and says let's visualize
something you have one thing in your
head but they have completely different
thing in their head and sometimes after
spending like hours on working on
something you could end up in situation
when well basically what you thought
you're making a visualization the people
for who you make visualization they have
completely different things in mind so
maybe they even don't any visualization
at all and in my talk I will show the
examples of matplotlip I love modular
clip I think it's widely used in well in
data science
uh but it's not restricted to my plot
leap you'll find the approach is
universal it's object-oriented approach
and you can apply it to any Library use
you use or you like
and we talk when we talk about
visualization actually the first
question that I ask myself for the
stakeholders that want that
visualization is uh what kind of
visualization do they need it can be the
static visualization or dynamic
visualization
static is something that people usually
put on reports like A4 paper and they
print it like I don't know weekly
monthly for their management Dynamic is
some the dashboard that requires some
action from people so they go to some
website they can interact with the data
yeah they can explore something but
that's a two big groups of data that we
can think of
but yeah
remember before quoting anything it's
very nice to align on your goals and the
fastest ways to align for me is to try
to get sense of data and maybe to draw
something
and that actually works well because you
can communicate with your partners is it
something that you need for example if
you have something running a B test
maybe you need to see how the well the
sales evolve over the time or if you
need to compare for example two
different algorithms between each other
so probably we'll pick some bar chart
and and see how it would look like
the key Point here is that yeah having
drawn that on piece of paper can allow
you to well to save some time later and
it also
nice to think about the corner cases
because for example if you visualize how
you wrote the awesome algorithm that
performs like in nanoseconds and another
algorithm is performs in seconds what
you couldn't end up with is just like
one huge bar for the poor algorithm and
very little bar that is well not visible
for your nice algorithm basically you
miscommunicate the message so you kind
of show that okay everything is okay
slow but you don't show what is
important your thing that you've been
working on
and again I mean the best visualization
library or tool is the one that you know
the most so it could be my plot leap or
it could be something else but yeah I
think at that point is a enough
hypothetical examples and let's get to
code and that's my favorite part and
when I start I need data visualization
project I start very simple you could
notice few things on the screen so on a
high level there are two directories the
first one is the dot GitHub guitar
directory and the second is the
directory for the project we are
starting
uh
we will go over each of them so the pi
data Berlin is the directory that
contains the data the plots that I used
for this
presentation and the dot GitHub folder
it contains the work GitHub workflow for
CI CD thing that I will show you why
it's important because in some time the
visualization project they tend to
become bulky and very unmaintainable but
on a high level if you structure like
that you'll see the benefits of of doing
that
and uh
why I like to introduce the continuous
visualization or continuous integration
in my into my project
is because it can work as a test
and also what I try to do with my
visualization I want every plot that I
create to be reproducible and for that I
simply like to put all the plots that I
ever create to the single file which I
called gallery.pdf and the continuous
integration it allows me to to create
this Gallery PDF file and as you can see
here it's the kind of plots that I
generate for this presentation and you
can find them on the GitHub workflow
attached to the like on the bottom
sometimes it's nice to well not to
introduce it like as a separate file but
having them in the code because maybe
you'll go and you'll show the GitHub
repo so for that case I sometimes put
some visualization in SVG format to the
readme file that also allows me to track
yeah and to Showcase what what what's in
my what what's my visualization code is
doing
if you remember the first thing that
said that I didn't know like what is
good and what is bad for data
visualization and in my practice I
usually use a few kind of plots it's
like a chart plot line plot bar
plot and tables and uh
the opening eye book that I kind of very
thankful that I discovered it it was
Roger scientific visualization python
Plus modplotlib
it's a very nice book that teaches you
the good design principles we can name
them one by one now they are
self-explanatory but I really advise you
to go after and to check out his book
he's like it's fantastic one if you use
my plot leap so basically the first one
is what I've started with it's like
knowing your audience is the key then
you need to identify the message adapt
figure to support the medium captions
are not optional don't trust the
defaults use color efficiently don't
mislead the reader avoid Char junk and
message Trump's Beauty and the final one
is they get the right tool
uh yeah all of them they were the
separate talk and actually there are
lots of talks around the design
principles that you can find online but
for me the main focus today is on
structuring the project
but let's look into action here so let's
consider this example of Roger from his
book how to make a good data
visualization so he creates a deep
showing that okay some things they are
redundant they just create a confusion
and if you try to optimize the graph
try to keep in mind the less is more and
that's actually the thing that I always
keep in my head when I creating the
visualization so in reality when you try
to show as much data as you can in the
end you may end up not showing anything
and what I like specifically about that
example is that yeah over time you see
how it evolved from very complex graph
to very simple one and even without
knowing the context oops it's switched
even without knowing the context you see
how author tries to emphasize that
something this bacon is going on so this
is the importance of clearing the
message for the audience
usually the line charts they are simple
but uh
I don't like the matplot leap defaults
and usually what I start when I
take a new library for data
visualization I start to explore with
basic things like that trying to
experiment how visualizations are
structured and how I should interact
with the framework by repeating this
basic chart so here you can see that
okay it doesn't look like a default
maplete figure however there are little
tweaks needs to be made and what you
could notice that the title is left
aligned the labels are directly on the
plot the while label is 90 degrees
rotated so we don't need to rotate our
hand well when we read the
the y-axis label
uh yeah so that's the first plot I make
if I try a new library or something with
my potlib it's quite easy because
everything in Python is an object you
know absolute clip is not exception so
everything in Python and then matplotlip
is an object so you can easily modify
their state before you I'll call the
figure show method
uh so let's continue and actually that's
what I showed that that's the first
thing that I do with my
plots uh you could not just few things
here so I simplify the code a bit so
that's easier to consume but you could
notice that I usually like to use the
python files instead of the jupyter
notebooks and for any plot that I create
I I name them as a plot underscore
something and in this case it's a plot
plot common chart and then that's what I
said first you create the two objects
the figure object and the access object
and then it's object-oriented approach
so you can easily modify
the attributes of your object to get to
the state that is presented here
uh in business domain I usually see the
things that people the data is complex
and people tend to use like okay on
average we have something X and I see
another value of data visualization and
here it's like the point that it's very
hard like it's very easy to mislead the
reader and I recently found that very
nice article that shows that you can get
the completely different data sets but
the same statistics and if you play this
give here you see that the data set
changes but the averages and all the
statistics they stay the same so that's
another argument of using the data
visualization is not to mislead the
reader so and don't mislead yourself so
usually people who requires data
visualization they're busy and what they
need to understand is like yeah we need
to think how to create the effective
visualization and don't mislead the
reader
if you go back to the structure so now
we have a complex like more complex uh
directory so it's basically the
directory for this presentation so you
could notice a few things so now I'm
showing you this SRC directory there are
a couple of python files uh most of them
they start with the plot something so
each of them are executable by itself so
for example if I want to reproduce the
sine function I'll just call plot sign
or if cosine plot cosine if plot waves I
just run python plot waves and it
generates me SVG plot yeah it's right
it's ready
uh
that approach works well for me why
because once I found myself like in a
very difficult situation when I had like
tons of jupyter notebooks where they
have like a pretty similar names with
Untitled something and I usually see
people using them it was a nightmare to
find like the the plot that I created
and to reproduce it and since then yeah
I learned that okay it's very nice to
separate your data from the data
visualization
and it also allowed me to structure the
project a bit differently and think a
bit differently so for example if I
would recreate a plot like that if I
would do it in a Jupiter notebook I
would probably create the first plot
and then if I would experiment with that
so for example imagine if I need to
change the color scheme I would copy
paste myself to the new cell I will
change the color scheme then I will
repeat this process for another
cell to get the third one and it's not
3D scalable so first you have this
endless Jupiter notebooks with manual
cells then you tune one cell
if you want this change to propagate to
any other cell so you have to repeat
this process again again
yeah it's not a good way to do it that's
how I do it now so basically yeah I have
a few functions so I already talked
about the plot underscore and visualized
underscore but you see how easy it is
because on the slide the third function
is the main function that generated this
three plots so you see that I create
like I read the data data believes
separately
I create the figure and axis containing
of three plots and then I just call the
methods and you can see by this
simplifying that okay there are also
some anti-patterns because yeah I call
the same function again again and then I
call this set title it also allows you
to think like how you can simplify your
uh your code another example is uh when
you need to experiment and yeah with the
data so data is static is separate from
your data visualization but sometimes
you need to convey the message to your
audience and that way it's quite easy so
on top it's not misleading graph but you
see all of other three misleans and why
because that's the same data but
different exercises and if I would write
the article saying that hey come on like
the global warming is uh like it's crazy
I would use that misleading graph with
exponential growth however there is no
exponential growth or maybe if I want to
convince people that okay the global
warming is like is
it doesn't exist I would use the graph
from the bottom it's the same data but
with the different access scales it
looks completely different and when you
yeah here it's not for visualizing like
and convincing you that yeah there is a
global warming or not but it's mostly
for the code that is written on the left
it's the same building blocks that I
used before I used to reproduce this
graph
that also brings us to another point you
see here the data visualization is
separate from the data itself so and the
tests are important and sometimes
you don't know how to write a test for
your data but you at least know
something so you know that okay your
temperature it would be a number it
wouldn't mean the string so you can
introduce some basic tests on your data
that yeah you you stay safe or for
example if you know that okay the
temperature of water it doesn't exist
the 100 degrees maybe it's nice idea to
introduce that test
even if it's like not doesn't show you
much but in case something fails for for
example your processing start returns
nouns you will know that okay your test
is failing because your data is not
integers anymore so you have this alert
way earlier than before
another thing that I found is that it's
very nice to Version Control the the
plots this way because as I said before
for me it was like endless amount of
notebooks and I didn't know how to use a
Version Control effectively but after I
split the data processing code with the
data visualization code it's quite easy
and another thing that I really liked is
that okay here I kind of get the GitHub
example but if you go to visual studio
code you can use a plugin to go back
into history and then if you introduce
any plots to your well GitHub repository
you can basically open the SVG file and
go back in the history and then you can
revert to any comment like in the past
because I mentioned that someone comes
to you and says that you need to change
anything so it would be quite easy with
this approach which is harder with
Jupiter notebooks in my practice
another thing that I found myself not
doing at some point and I'm doing it now
learned by
Yeah by my experience is that not
setting up the health checks and
remember when I said that it's nice to
have the gallery.pdf file
it works kind of a test for me because
anytime the data changes the gallery PDF
file will also change and for example I
can introduce the simple GitHub workflow
here that is self-explanatory so you
basically execute the python code which
is on the bottom so you I call assemble
plots dot Pi that assembles all my plot
functions and generate the PDF file and
I know that if I change anything in my
plot if any of the plot function fails
the workflow will fail I'll get an email
and I can go and fix it so I immediately
notified that something goes wrong and I
can do it in a pull request so yeah
before merging to the main I already
know that
and that's for example how my assemble
dot
how do you call it assemble assemble
plots file looks like so it may look
complex but it's not but the key is on
the line for a file in path parent Globe
plot underscore Pi so what it does it
reads all the plot underscore python
files on your directory and at Imports
all methods that starts with plot
underscore and it executes them it
executes them and adds the plot to
gallery.pdf so that's why in a big
project I found it very useful to yeah
have this
gallery.pdf file where you can just go
and showcase to people
you might think of that okay I'm not
coding so we have a static environment
like tableau grafana
uh yeah here I also learned some lessons
and
I made some changes to production
dashboard that actually are not supposed
to be there and yeah from my experience
now I always keep two instances of the
production dashboards so I have my
staging dashboard and I have my
production dashboard and before
introducing any change in data or in
visualization and pro dashboard I do it
in staging environment communicate with
the stakeholders if they are fine I push
the changes to prod
knowing the limits it's mostly about the
data processing algorithms that you use
because sometimes you
yeah you write the test and it works for
your specific case
but maybe if you increase the data like
a thousands of times it will stop
working or maybe your algorithm works
for a month but if you continue doing
that way so in 12 months it's just stop
working so another benefit of knowing
the limits is just like write a simple
test multiply your data by a factor of
1000 or million whatever you load is and
see if it will continue to work because
you could end up in situation where
yeah where you need to reproduce
something or you need to create a plot
but you cannot because you need to
refactor your code or optimize something
and basically yeah that's my journey
through this data visualization
horror movie now I feel myself a bit
better knowing those things but before
it was not the case the main messages
are like work collaboratively with your
partners aim for reproducibility and for
me the Version Control is the key so I
know that any at any point of time I can
reproduce any graph
back up the data version the code setup
money touring and create a continuous
pipeline that can help you to identify
the bugs and probably save you not life
but save you lots of time in the long
run thank you and I'm open for questions
thank you
before we can go to questions I would
like to summarize again very briefly
please pick up your race bands for the
social event at the registration desk as
early as possible
also there is the lost and found desk if
you have lost anything
please pick up your pie ladies wristband
if you are interested
also the next presentation which would
be held in this room was shifted so
there's no presentation next in this
room
now we can get to the questions after I
thank artium for this great presentation
I think the drawings were so cool
if you have any questions just write
them down at slido also just vote the
other questions up please
first question
how do you test the graphics you
generate is it manual by eye or do you
have some method of automatic yeah
that's a great question actually I write
a test for my data visualization also
because I found myself once uh it's
again it's related to reproducibility
and if you remember from one slide when
I separate the data from data
visualization I had a line that says
like pandas read CSV blah blah blah so
in my one in one case I draw a line plot
where it was like accepting a column X
and a column y but it accepted all the
columns that starts for with Y my data
changed over the time so and I created a
very nasty plot with the same plotting
function where I had like not one line
on my plot but tens of lines so what I
test I test that okay I know that this
specific grab that I shipped to my stay
my my customers it consists of two lines
and since everything in Python is an
object you can and write a simple test
saying that okay get the access object
and ensure that the number of lines is
equal to two this is the basic test that
I write every time now maybe there are
other tests uh yeah we can just yeah
just think what what is your
visualization and write the test to
ensure that is there
next question
matplotlib versus Seaborn versus Altair
well it's very hard question for me I
love Motley clip because it's like a
tool that well I feel the most
comfortable with but any other tool is
great so it's just like it's individual
preferences but it's also related to the
domain because I when I usually create
the data visualization I create them for
reports and those reports are usually
static they are printed on the paper and
in that scenario my plot leap is well
it's it's a winner for me because I can
tune any any object under my plot
there's time for just one more question
question to the global warning example
when plotting temperature versus time
there is no obvious scale so how do you
decide what axis scaling is not
misleading yeah actually that's a good
question and in some books there are
some recommendations but what I found
myself doing is that uh experimenting
with scale and trying to show and
communicate with people and just showing
them the graph and asking like if what
what you can say looking into the graph
because if you remember the bar chart
example that I showed you that before
had like five colors for each bar and in
the end like it was down to one selected
bar and I say that okay here the message
is clear that authors wanted to say
something about bacon and the same works
for the data visualization like with the
line charts so I could end up like with
a few examples of the different accesses
and then I'll just discuss with people
with whom I work like what you can say
like yeah which one would you prefer or
in my own judgment I could see that hey
this is bad this looks better so maybe
it's less biased
again thank you for your great talk
thank you